[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a on a hâte un très gros niveau de
chocolat temps on a repris très fort la
saison à bercy christophe qui a été
modifié pour aprilia peut-être obligés
de verser les droits fort boyard parce
que ça c'est typiquement des émissions
forme d un oui mais je sais que tu sais
que je suis un peu producteurs de fort
boyard verso à moi même de l'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si patrice cohen merci messi théâtre
deux minutes il peut le présenter aussi
je suis bien avec vous mr allez mon dj
d'amour qui était pas là hier il nous a
manqué en plus j'ai vu qu'hier vous avez
parlé de koh lanta
ouais moi j'adore cette saison parce que
c'est la première fois que je connais
personnellement un des candidats non on
connaît tous ici c'est le chroniqueur de
tpm p sacha elbaz
non ça chaque je fais partie de l'équipe
des bleus c'est pas vrai mais c'est la
personne
d'ailleurs ça cha cha cha aubin vraiment
quelqu'un de fiable à illac une parole
et il reviendra jamais sur ce qu'il a
dit jamais il pourrait vautrer contre la
maman du groupe vous imaginez quel genre
de personne ce serait serré que ce
serait moche c'est à ce qu'amazon
pourrait avoir le pied sortir ce sens là
bas juste après ce serait marrant de
carolis et en corrèze chez nous ça
n'arriverait j'adore votre christophe
nous on est unis c'est vrai je leur ai
dit vous inquiétez pas et vous arrivera
rien voilà a par contre tu me ça va me
coûter très cher fin le chocolat allez
vas-y toi et d'amis et away celle d'un
contrôle technique ou d'une vidange on
va le faire
il ya vraiment que dans koh lanta qu'on
peut voir des trahisons comme ça c'est
que si on prend par exemple un dîner
presque parfait on voit jamais ce genre
de la prison ferme jamais personne ne
retourne sa veste comme ça mais
franchement je te dis champions
franchement c'était ça va mais c'était
pas top et tout de suite ces moments du
zapping quoi mais un zapping dans sa
chronique ou djité vraiment génie a fait
une autre chronique ludique c'est parti
dans c'est mon choix et bling thomas
sait comment faire des jolis compliments
à ses invités est ce que on a l'habitude
de vous dire que vous ressemblez à votre
chien
oui trés trés ce dîner presque parfait
on n'est pas à fond à fond sur l'hygiène
je ferai tout ce qui n'est pas rien
surtout qu'elle est là on n'est pas là
pour lancer des rumeurs mais emmanuel
macron serait positif au commis de 19
dans les amours on a retrouvé le
dragueur le plus gros loup du monde tu
vas un dragueur relou pour l'aborder je
vais envoyer une photo de moi aux
toilettes
elle a adoré alors on n'est pas là pour
lancer des rumeurs mais quand même sur
idf1 une super voyante arrive à deviner
un truc qu'on vient de lui dire juste
avant mon voyage c'est un voyage cet été
ils y auront l'effet d'acquis qui arrive
oui vous vouliez bouger plus loin à la
base parce que seulement il est agréé en
voyage
alors oui y aura mes choix et choix
puisque quelque chose pas loin en tout
cas
la chanteuse brigitte fontaine c'est
nous donner envie de venir à son concert
on s'est toujours pourri mais là ça va
être encore plus pourri que jean nuit
mais encore une fois on n'est vraiment
pas là pour lancer des rumeurs
maintenant que la cac qui touche sans
bois touche mais pour l'instant il ya
bien sûr personne n'a dit que yvert
savez le logo vite disparu voilà
et il ay respecte les gestes de sécurité
apparemment bien d'accord à quoi il
s'est fait tester ce matin ah oui
pourquoi vous êtes avec lui ça vous
regarde le premier ministre il est passé
le brigitte hakim rien sans rien
comprendre
voilà ce qui l'aurait pas peuvent même
pas mieux fait de rappel coronavirus
[Rires]
de france il ya des coureurs qui
maîtrise dans bello à la perfection
et puis à lui alors à votre avis que
disent les commentateurs à le pour ce
coureur a dû avoir très mal mais le
pauvre panneaux a dû avoir très mal
c'est chez oudeh oui mais ils ont
cherché un peu quand même
non il faut
j'ai encore bravo hier tu étais où
j'étais sur mon cas la tranquille ou en
train de mater mon émission préférée et
convention citoyenne sur public sénat ah
oui quand même
et ça donnait ça les conditions pour
faciliter l'acceptation de cette mesure
dans la société et à la même heure sur
ces huit c'était deux salles deux
ambiances
sur france 5 un pinocchio animalier à
l'exception de ceux nés dans la réserve
comme lui la plupart des éléphants qui
vivent ici ont été exploitées par
l'homme les jeux rose ap sur ces 8 sur
france info les missions soyons clair de
mon temps chaque semaine à l'atelier
faire si tu ne dois rien de commenter
l'actualité
et c'est plus fort que moi je remets ses
[Applaudissements]
ap le chanteur michel
alors attention vos dictionnaires vos
bécherel aux encyclopédies risque de
prendre feu c'est l'heure du nyc sa
grammaire jason je ne calcule pas il a
le ciom que je ne calcule pas varta
angel calcul à elle et moi je suis
plutôt calculatrice vous prenez trop ce
jeu pour une excuse pour avoir des
comportements immoraux genre c'est parti
c'est l'ex a aussi un des favoris du roi
des choses pas les choses sont pas des
prostituées qui sait qu'une envie c'est
de faire rentrer my back est mon ami
donc quoi qu'il arrive je vais pas de
crise
là c'est vrai que j'aime bien mais
pendant qu'ils la charrette avant la
deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faiza ne faut pas envoyer la charrette
alors je vous vois venir d'ici ouais la
télé réalité ils sont ils en français
vous arrêtez tout de suite
alors ok et son huile en français mais
sont aussi nuls en culture générale a
mené au score je regarde de près via le
trou suit pas mieux pris via le trou
suite c'est trivial pursuit avec des
questions un peu plus simple et des
réponses un peu moins bonnes qui a été
le premier président de la cinquième
république française
madore est le premier nom de paris fall
of heroes rappelle droitier
[Musique]
mode multi du festival de cannes qui est
le président actuel du résident
[Applaudissements]
c'est hallucinant génial à l'uci et ça
marche
oui ça car c'est ça le progrès vous
voulez la voulait que j'aille là-bas
aussi pardon vous méfier là bas aussi on
ne sait trop bien merci
dans les marseillais s'étaient atelier
cuisine au menu un bon poulet rôti mais
avant de le manger il faut d'abord le
vider et on sent que jessica et julien
ils ont fait ça toute leur vie
soulignent demande sortir
[Musique]
alors jessica la cuisine c'est pas trop
son truc mais regardez là quand même
devrait lui une belle carrière de
ventriloque tremble jeff pas la clope tu
vas entendre
[Rires]
mais si la réduction dernier un petit
dernier toujours dans les marseillais et
ati moment tendresse un moment détente
où on profite pour une fois que ça crie
pas tué je n'ai pas touché
m
manille